hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
weed wackos that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
for me marijuana legalizations a social
justice issue it's a racial justice
issue it's an economic justice issue uh
and I think the War on Drugs has been an
abject failure
it was supposed to be a model for the
rest of the nation big Venture Capital
firms raised 25 million dollars to help
pass California's prop 64 back in 2016.
and they argue that marijuana
legalization would not only keep people
out of jail for using small amounts of
weed but it would also reduce crime by
squeezing out the illegal drug Market
well that didn't work out far from
reducing illegal weed those efforts
instead allowed the black market to
flourish after legalization with the
help of organized crime operations that
run massive unlicensed farms and
storefront dispensaries in plain view
bringing crime and terrorizing nearby
residents and those raided by police are
often up and running again within weeks
or even days
now you know what kills the LA Times to
publish these stories but the broken
promises of legalization with the
violence and the illegal grows they're
just impossible to ignore
and what's happening in all the other
states that legalized it well in Maine
where adult use of cannabis is legal and
sales are regulated the Chinese have
stepped in to undercut prices by
starting their own illegal operations
and it's so bad that now State lawmakers
and Maine's two senators are asking the
feds for help
now of course most of these politicians
still aren't against cannabis
legalization they just want to protect
the legal Market from being again
undercut by the criminals
but again that's what they promised
legalization would do
and you walk around Manhattan lately as
I have all that horrid pot smell it's
everywhere little kids have to breathe
it in it's like we're all walking around
in a big pit of burning manure mixed
with skunk smell no one I know likes it
that when the Big Apple reeks of dirty
diapers people say what if people aren't
going to take out the the trash or the
trash collection isn't happening no no
no it's not the garbage in the street
it's the legalization that has
destigmatized the use of marijuana even
in front of children
the number one thing I smell right now
is pot it's like everybody is smoking a
joint now you know
um you know everybody has a joints
what an idiot oh yeah it's hilarious
mayor just like what actually happens to
school age kids when the THC infused
gummies or snacks or Vapes are
everywhere post legalization
doctors have been warning about this by
the way for years
but the biggest problem that has
happened in every state that has
legalized marijuana are a big spike in
emergency room visits because of people
overdosing and the Edibles some of which
are kids because these look like gummy
bears
it's only gotten worse nevertheless
there's big money in them dare pot
fields and this year States like New
Hampshire North Carolina Ohio and
Pennsylvania are all likely to vote to
legalize marijuana
and remember California wants to
experiment even more despite its own
experience with this by legalizing other
mind-altering drugs
the state senate there just approved a
bill to decriminalize so-called magic
mushrooms and psychedelics oh they're
all good for you well keep them numb and
dumb and hope that you collect more in
tax revenue than you lose in human lives
and revenue from all the Cannabis linked
overdose deaths mental health problems
car crashes education loss and of course
the added expense of law enforcement
now of course Libertarians think that
the problem with cannabis legalization
is that again it didn't go far enough so
get all the other drugs out there too
they want all drugs legalized even
Fentanyl
but maybe we should ask Oregon about its
own experience with allowing hard drug
use in public places
Portland went from 413 shooting
incidents in 2019 before legalization to
1309 afterward
now no wonder Portland city leaders are
trying to reverse course there turn
around the legalization of hard drug use
in public overdoses are multiplying so
are a long list of social pathologies
there
but the fact is it's not just hard drugs
talk to addicts almost every one of them
started on weed despite the lies we're
told about how it's never a gateway drug
well it's true it's not a gateway drug
for everyone or maybe even most people
but it is for most of those sad souls
that you see staring into space
muttering to themselves in the streets
and for all the liberals who love to
talk about the science the science on
what regular THC use does to the
developing brain well it's devastating
from Psychology today highly
concentrated marijuana products are
causing cannabis-induced psychosis
paranoia and confusion increase
marketing on social media may send a
message to teens that cannabis is safe
and harmless and of course it does
now parents who've lost children to
marijuana have had about enough of the
glorification of the drug and the
Relentless lies told about its claimed
benefits
he very quickly became addicted five
years later he died by Suicide saying
that the mob was after him we don't have
a mob that UNC was an FBI base that
everybody knew everything about him he
became completely delusional
it's heartbreaking and infuriating and
all too common
no matter how much money that state
governments get from Cannabis sales
taxing them and it's a lot it's not
worth it
it's time for all 50 states to see the
cruel lessons of drug legalization
especially for our kids
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else